Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
Is Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 28th,
2016 that I'm doing on November 29th at Tuesday. What's going on? How, why
I'm I am okay. Case you are wondering. I got a little, uh, I don't know.
I got a little S. I've been fighting off this car for like two fucking weeks.
Who's kidding? Who? Right. And I, uh, you know,
I was fighting off and it was getting worse and Nia kept going.
Why don't you take some medicine?
Why don't I take tech some of this new thing next? All right.
Holy Shit.
Half fucking my hats off to anybody that can get fucking drunk off their,
that stuff. Jesus Christ.
That's like peppermint Schnapps Times fucking 20.
I really is Mucin X. It's like schnapps on steroids. It's just, you know,
one of the, you know,
the other others have these dumb champ challenges like the mannequin challenge.
I don't understand. What is the challenge?
Just hold still is somebody pans around the room.
That's a fucking challenge.
How the fuck did we go from faking a lunar landing fake in that faking out the
whole fucking Russians. And they got so freaked out that day. Day One,
they went on a hissy fit for the next fucking 30 years before they finally went
broke. Right in the early nineties cause we,
we accepted the challenge of the faking of the lunar land.
Maybe we even got there, the Luna land landing challenge.
Now we're fucking all the mannequin. Oh, planking. Yeah.
I lay face down and somebody takes a picture of me. Oh dude, that's epic.
Jesus Christ. I don't know you what the f you know what it is,
is these fucking goddamn cuts. Young people these days, you know, no offense,
right? God bless his,
let's say fucking spend their whole lives with these fucking reality,
virtual reality. God Damn things on their head. They're playing video games.
They don't have any skills. The second you take the fucking laptop,
you take the fucking laser tag thing, the pink gun,
whatever the fuck technology is. The thing that, you know, that new thing that,
that, that they're trying to get old people into the virtual reality, like,
like live in a fucking life is, it isn't enough.
Like I want to leave this fucking world really is, you saw it all, huh?
You're been to Venice, rode a boat through the fucking canal.
You haven't done shit. All right, so this is the deal.
They don't fucking know how to fucking do anything.
Is this such an old man rent not to do anything.
They're just fucking literally laying face down in the road. You know,
and somebody takes a picture. Is, is this is, it's epic.
It's fucking epic. Now granted in the 70s, they did have pet rock,
so I might be full of Shit. But you know what it is,
the great thing about being old is you lack perspective.
When you talk about anything new, you're just like, dad's different.
It scares me. Um,
I don't get the mannequin challenge. I don't, you know, and that,
that was like the, when they also had the, uh,
whatever the Harlem shake was initially it was a dance and then it was just that
stupid youtube thing, the ice bucket challenge, all of that Shit,
you know, if your instincts aren't immediately to not be part of the group, um,
I don't know what that says about you.
I don't want to says about me that I immediately ice buck or everybody's doing
it. Well then fucking I'm not doing it. Oh yeah.
Anti social sick. Freckled headed bald cunt. What's wrong with you today?
Hang on a second. Rico law.
Yes. I've been fighting this fucking thing off. You know, I have a bad feeling.
It might be one this cigar that I got that there's something in there,
some sort of bacteria because I was fine.
And then I smoked with Versie on his birthday and then I smoked with Bobby Kelly
had fucking comics come home back to back nights.
And then I just had this fucking cough. You don't,
it's not like he inhaled the goddamn things.
It's not like I smoke one every fucking day.
I smoked one like once every two weeks. Oh,
they've been on a little bit of a bender. Okay. Um, so anyways,
so Sunday night, you know, it's been a good 15 days since I smoked out. Right.
I'll smoke. Another one went down with my buddy.
We watched the Broncos chiefs game,
arguably the greatest Sunday night football game ever.
I lost track of how many fucking lead changes there were. Um,
just, you know, and I wasn't drinking. I haven't drank since thanksgiving.
I kind of bottomed out thanksgiving. Right. You know what's back.
I had a great thanksgiving, by the way. Great fucking thanksgiving. Um,
we ended up day. Talk about that already. I think I already did.
Maybe I didn't. I don't remember. I started talking. I hadn't gone to it yet.
That's right. That's what it was. Listen to this shit.
We went to somebody else's for Thanksgiving and everything was fucking
delicious. Every side was fucking not only delicious,
it was a home run. It's the best thanksgiving I've had since I've been a kid.
When I ate my mom, my parents house, you know, my mother cooked.
So it just automatically tastes right. Cause that's the only thanksgiving,
you know? Right. But that once you move out,
you're eating other people's food and no matter what,
it's always a little bit different. It's not quite the same.
You get that feeling of, fuck, it's over.
I have to pay rent now I'm going to get old. Right?
I'm going to be that person.
What happened to him and then I fucking die and blah blah, blah,
Blah Blah and all that bullshit. Right? So anyways,
we had a great fucking Thanksgiving and I had this fucking bottle of Bourbon
that I brought. That was my responsibility. When the fuck is my phone,
I gotta give this thing a shout out man. You know,
they say you can't judge a book by by its fucking cover. Um,
I actually judged this bottle of just by how cool the fucking bottle looked.
So let me scroll through my, it was called angels in something or other,
by the way,
it rain like a motherfucker out here and I have water collecting up on my roof.
Again, fucking cons. It's unbelievable.
It's just fucking, it's just, it's just not even right.
So I got to get the third fucking people out here to see if they know how to fix
it. Ah, God damn. And I thought I took a picture of it. Nah, I gotta find it.
Hang on a second. You know, I'm gonna hit pause. I'll hit pause. All right.
I found it. Angels envy. It's a Kentucky Bourbon.
God dammit. Was that delicious? And uh, me and two other people, a,
we finished the bottle and, uh, I dunno,
I got like to my last one and I was just like, you know what? I think this,
uh, I think it's time for me to shut it down. You know,
maybe once in awhile the drinking just gets a little bit too fucking far and
then I just shut it down. So I walked away cold Turkey, thanksgiving night,
cold Turkey. I buck and walked away from it. And um,
you know,
I'm not gonna lie to you. I miss it. It's only been four days.
I'm still thinking about you sending out letters and shit. Um, yeah,
I'm just going to shut it down probably until, um,
I'd say maybe the Rose Bowl New Year's day or whatever. I already got it,
shut it down and get a fucking kid come. And so it's over. You know what,
you know what people, I gotta be honest. I had a great run.
I got the stories, you know, I spent a few,
a few hours in jail. I mean, I've done, you know, went to court.
I had the whole, you know, had to apologize to people.
I had a very full experience with alcohol, you know,
talk to some chicks that were way out of my league. You know, I,
I did it. I had the whole thing, you know,
stayed on the outskirts of bar fights to make sure that I didn't get pummeled.
So that's it. So anyways, um, believe it or not, as bad as my coughs sounds,
it's way better than it was fucking yesterday. I was going,
I wasn't going to put you through that shit. So anyways, so Sunday night, yeah,
smoked a number of those cigars. And yesterday I woke up, I just,
I was having a fucking coffin fit. Granted I was already run down.
So yesterday, um, I didn't do shit.
I gotta tell you that was like the greatest six hours of my life,
not doing shit. But somewhere in that six hour, uh,
after the six hours I was going out of my fucking mind.
I don't know how you guys do it, you know, not you guys.
Just whoever the fuck is out there that just can just truly take a god Damn Day
off. Like I go fucking nuts. After six hours was great. I laid there,
I watched like two, three episodes of, um,
Westworld getting caught up.
I'm up to like episode a six I'm going to watch today. Right?
And I'm loving that show.
Although he can't watch more than two or three a day, it's just too much, man.
It's like you just gotta be, you know,
it's a lot of shit going on to kind of take in and then also having now doing my
own little show, that's only a half hour. When I look at that show,
I just think of like, how fucking long did it take them to do this?
And then I'm going to sit here and I'm going to watch it in two days and then be
that douche going when season two coming out. You know, it's like,
it's a fine bottle of wine and I'm just going to Chug the thing, you know,
after the third glass, I'm not really tasting it anymore cause I'm so hammered.
I might as well be drinking like fucking red, white and Blue Beers. Some shit,
right. Just doesn't seem right. So anyways,
that's what I did yesterday and um, I'm feeling much better. Thank Christ. So,
um, by the way, today's November 29th, which is, uh,
the five year anniversary since the passing of one of the funniest and greatest
people I ever met Patrice O'Neil,
speaking of which there are still some tickets left for the, uh,
the fifth annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit. Um,
all the proceeds after we pay for the, uh, the venue. Of course,
our only expense, um, you know,
it goes to all of his loved ones. That's been a tremendous success.
And this year we have, we have, um,
let's get the whole line up here for God's sakes. For God's sakes.
We got Leslie Jones, we got rich foss, we got Bobby Kelly,
Keith Robinson, Gary Gulman, Dan Soda, Soda,
right. And Myself, um,
there's going to be another great year of, um,
I'm just getting to see all those people, you know,
I never get to see them anymore cause I'm always out here gigging on the road or
living out here in La Bababababa bus. So, um,
that's going to be a Tuesday,
February 21st at the New York City Center. And um,
you know, it's just a, it's just a great event and um,
thank you to everybody who's come to it in the past years and um,
you've guys have done a wonderful thing. Um,
keeping all his loved ones comfortable.
And I'm very proud of that whole charity thing because, um,
you know, as tragic as it was that he was gone,
I'm very proud of the fact that all of his friends stepped up and that all of
his loved ones or comfortable,
cause I know that that's what he would have been concerned with. So with that,
um,
I'm actually doing another benefit for those who can't make it to New York City.
If you're in the La area and you would like to, um,
you'd like to help out on another benefit.
I have another buddy of mine that died.
So what happens when you get into your forties, man, it's fucking brutal.
Is a couple of your buddies die too young man, it's awful. This guy,
Pete and I started out with him in, um, 1992, um,
did stand up with them from 92 to 99 and then he moved on to writing with
National Lampoon. He did some stuff for the UFC. Just a great guy. Unfortunately
he had a heart attack a few weeks ago and about a month ago. So, uh, Tuesday,
December 6th at the laugh factory.
I'll be doing a headlining set there and I'm a bunch of pizza friends from back
in the day, a bunch of comics. We haven't all been on the same show in forever.
Probably 20 years. We'll be a going on, um, earlier in the night.
Uh, it's going to be a great thing and a, it's a memory of him. So there you go.
So enough with the, uh, friends of mine that have passed away unfortunately. Um,
let's talk about some shit here. I fi I got a wife,
I've got to give a shout out to fucking Nico Rosberg when in his first Formula
One championship, um,
the final few laps of that race were amazing. Right?
For those of you who are not into it, basically what the situation was,
Lewis Hamilton had won the last three. Nico Rosberg had never won.
They both drive from Mercedes. Okay. So Nico's,
the young upstart Louis is the grizzled vet,
even though they're both fucking young.
It was kind of like days of thunder of both.
Both people look like fucking Tom Cruise is basically it, right?
It's like two tongue, the old Tom Cruise, right? Scientology,
Tom Cruise versus fucking, um,
what was that movie that they will all in where they were the, the,
the socials in the greasers the fuck was that movie called? I knew that one.
Okay.
Ah, God dammit. What was it called? Matt Dylan was in it.
Emilio Estevez Istep as, ah,
the dirty dancing guy. Roadhouse guy. The karate kid was in it.
Tom Cruise was in it.
Who else was in that fucking movie? Everybody was in that fucking movie.
Everybody like there was like nine people in that fucking movie.
They had all went, uh, see Thomas Howell.
They all went on to star and movies that made,
I would love to see how much fucking box office, every,
every guy that started as a greaser in that movie ended up making. You know,
you got to hate being the one fucking greaser that didn't make it right.
That's when you just got to look at yourself like, dude,
what the fuck everybody in this ensemble cast?
I got to find out what it is now. All right, Tom Cruise I m.
D. B. How do you spell Cruz wrong?
I somehow spelled it with to use eos. Tom fucking crows.
Toyos all right. There he is. Smiling, looking sort of normal.
As normal as he possibly can. Well, what the outside,
oh, the outsiders. All right, here we go. Let's, let's this,
this is the fucking lineup. See Thomas how Matt Dillon, Ralph Machio.
Patrick Swayze. Rob fucking low.
Emilio Estefan is Tom Cruise.
Okay.
Alright. That alone right there. One, three, four, five,
six.
The first seven guys all went on to star in movies.
Tom Cruise alone has done billions in box office. Matt Dillon,
the amount of money he's done, Ralph Machio, the fucking karate kid.
Patrick Swayze, dirty dancing alone. Forget about ghost,
right when they were in the claymation class and what did,
and he comes up behind her and they go, oh wow.
The time of my life would be Goldberg grabbing your tits.
I swear. Emilio Estevez Right. He was in stakeout.
He was in fucking, uh, the breakfast club.
Um,
he was in the cowboy movies, right? And he played Billy the kid. Gigamon,
you know, all these fucking people are, and you got a guy like Glenn Withrow.
The fuck happened to him. Diane Lane, she was in my leaf, Garrett. Jesus Christ.
He sold a bunch of albums. Tom Waits was in that fucking movie.
Then there was a William Smith who plays the store clerk. You went by William,
if you went by will, you know, could've been a whole different story.
So anyways, I don't even know what the fuck I'm too. Oh yeah. So Nico Rosberg,
right? So here's the deal.
The way the points worked out was Louis Hamilton had the win. The fucking race
provided Niko didn't crash, all right? If Nico was going to finish the race,
Louis had to win the race and Nico had to become in fourth place or worse,
and then Louis would have won his fourth in a row. Okay.
But a lot of three peak out there for not nobody.
Who the fuck does four in a row? You never see that shit, right?
So it comes down to the law.
All Niko had to do was finish in third place in no matter what Lewis Hamilton
did, the shit was over. So you get down to like five fucking laps to go.
Nico Rosberg he's in third place, he's a fucking lunatic.
He passes the thing. It was a red bull car and all the guys,
I love the guys who announced it, they're always so fucking cool.
Like whenever there's a pat Ho Cho go god, they're always doing that shit.
It's like, dude, do you have money in that car? Is that your son in there?
I mean, after reason we're watching this shit. It's to see him crash.
It's like watching hockey. Half of it's to watch the game.
The other half is to watch somebody beat the fuck out of somebody. I want,
I want to see somebody spin around a little bit. You know,
I want to see a fender. Right.
So anyways, uh, so get senator. The last five laps,
Nico goes around, whoever the fuck was in second place.
How can burger or fucking one of those other guys are Timo Nikunen,
Timo, Salani I dunno. Anything, any of the other drivers yet.
It's my first year watching it, right? He fucking passes the guy.
Now he's in second place. So now loads just like what the fuck.
So Lewis Hamilton starts slowing down,
trying to let the third and fourth place cars catch up,
which they're doing all right. Now they're a fucking team.
They're on the same team. So evidently when the head dude at Mercedes,
you know, if you're on the Mercedes teams,
if your team calls you and tells you to do something,
you're not supposed to disobey a direct order. I'm telling you,
this is like top gun and fucking
Jay's the thunder. Sorry. It's just a little touch of a bullet people, right?
So he gives [inaudible], they give Lewis a direct order to go and Louis a,
you gotta drive faster here. Come on. We want to win this race.
And Lewis just says,
he just says back into the radio on TV,
basically said, um, well, um,
I'm still in first place and I'm comfortable with my current position,
basically. Meaning like,
I'm not going to drive any fucking faster and I'm good enough that even if
Nico's right on my ass, I know he's not going to try to go around me, you know,
risking crashing cause he's got it. So for the last five fucking laps you,
I just on the edge of your fucking seat,
like is this guy in third place going to go around Nico Rosberg um,
he didn't, Lewis Hamilton disobeyed a direct order.
I believe Robert Duvall came out in the end and started screaming at somebody.
I can't remember, but um, it was kind of funny like whenever,
like they're both on the podium, which was almost every race this year.
Nico and Lewis like wouldn't even look at each other. It was fucking like,
oh my God, I'm not even talking to you right now. I'm like,
so like not even talking to you right now.
Like it was that whole fucking energy.
So when Nico wins the thing,
they actually shook hands and there was some fucking clown interview and them
going, Oh, I kind of blocked a shot. Can you guys do that again? It was great.
And then they just sort of begrudgingly shook hands or whatever and the guy just
goes, oh, that's great. It's, it's all good. Again, if something like that,
it's like, dude, it's very far from all good again. So, um,
I believe this season starts up again, either the end of March or the,
or the beginning of April. And uh,
I jumped on this year after they raced in Monaco and I had a great time fucking
watching it.
I actually started to think of the sheer amount of fucking money it must cost to
have a Goddamn to run a Formula One team.
I can't imagine how much fucking money you got to ship that car around the
fucking world like nine times. And you know,
you got a couple of other cars you've got to bring with it.
It's got to cost you $1 billion. It has to, does it bill?
Have you ever tried to ship even your fucking Prius to Connecticut? No.
So then you really don't know how much it costs. Ah, you got me. Whatever.
I know it's got to cost a lot of fucking money there, right.
So anyways, anybody watch Ohio State, Michigan?
I know this is kind of old games, but I don't give a fuck.
Did you guys watch that?
It's one of the best games I've seen between those two and a long fucking time.
And um, Michigan just kept fucking up when they got the ball.
They had the Goddamn game one. Do you notice how, what's his face there? The,
for whatever reason, I can never remember the last name.
The fucking coach in Michigan. Jim Harbaugh. Ah,
do you notice he was wearing the woody Hayes glasses?
I actually had a theory that if they won,
he was going to take the glasses off on their fucking logo on the 50 yard line
and steps stomp on him. You know, like after Jewish people get married,
they step on the fucking glass. He was going to do that with the fucking his,
his woody Hayes glasses.
And I loved that he called out the referee in and all that shit. You know,
I'm not saying I 100% agreed with them and all that shit, but uh, you know,
I thought they got to call right on there.
First down I stood up to when I saw live action, I was like, yeah.
And then I saw a fuck. He got it. I thought he got it anyways.
Um, but all my Michigan Buddies, they were all texting me.
That was a home job and all this type of shit. So who do you like guys?
It's probably gonna be Alabama, right? That had a nice,
had an easy time with fucking Auburn. She,
the kicker for Auburn, he grew up in an Alabama family.
Rolltide family in Alabama didn't give him a scholarship,
so he goes to fucking Auburn now and his grandfather calls him turncoat fucking
lunatics down there. Right. Scary Danielson. The whole game keeps going.
Goes turncoat kicking it for three.
I didn't think this podcast is remotely funny, but maybe,
maybe he just laughing at me coughing up a fucking lung hair. Um,
anyway, so it's going to be Alabama
and I'm going to say it's going to be Ohio state for the championship and his
old Billy red face having only watched about 15 college games this year,
having never played beyond the third grade level. This is my prediction.
All right. Organized. Anyways,
I played enough pickup football for the first time I ever threw up my back was
playing fucking football and uh, it's never been the same, you know?
No, it's not the first time.
The first time was when that kid put me in the figure four leg lock and fourth
grade outdoor recess. That's the first time I threw it out.
The next time was playing football.
And then the third time was another wrestling thing.
I tried to lift my younger brother up over my head, like Tony Atlas and the,
the upper third of my spine folded. It felt like, and uh,
you know, that's given me problems ever since then. You know,
that's probably why I leaned on the mic stand. Anyways, plowing ahead here.
I think it's going to be, it's going to be fucking Ohio state, Alabama.
Obviously.
I'm picking the number one and two teams and I think a Alabama Beats Ohio state
this time simply because I thought Iowa state had a lot of problems with debt
defense there in Michigan. Um,
and I think Alabama's defense is even better and Alabama's off fence is not
going to make the fucking mistakes that Michigan's, um, offense made.
You know,
you don't watch an Alabama team and they fumble a fucking snap on the one yard
line. They just don't do shit like that. You know what I mean?
Cause what's his face? Nick Saban that Luna ticket,
he probably fucking waterboard you know how angry a dude, you know,
that guy makes me feel good about my anger when I see that guy.
I was joking about this,
I did a Jeff's this areas podcast and we were fucking joking about,
my favorite fucking thing to do is to watch Alabama going in like down by seven
and half time.
I love when the halftime reporter comes up and starts talking to Nick Saban and
the, the, the look of fucking anger on his face.
All he wants to do is go into the locker room and call everybody's mother a cunt
that's wearing his uniform. Right?
But he's got to sit there and talk to some chick on the side like I like,
so why do you think it is your dad? [inaudible]
yes. It just sit there. You know,
he just wants to slap the wig right up for fucking head. But he doesn't do it.
He doesn't doe it. They sits there with his fucking,
I dunno what it is on his head. You know,
he makes Donald Trump look like fucking a Fabio.
I'm trying to think of somebody who's good here.
Who the fuck even has good heroin. You never even know anymore, right?
Everybody goes around, they get, they get the troops from the Beck, you know,
PLM, but the potatoes get put out right up on the front line.
Now is now what they do.
Then everybody goes swimming and nobody knows what's going on. Right? Tell you.
It takes a real man like myself to walk around looking like Charlie Brown.
I'm telling you. Red, redheaded, Charlie Brown. Um, anyways,
let's read some advertising here for this week everybody.
Let's see what we got here on the docket. How about those?
Bruins finally went in a game, right? Second I started watching.
They go into a three game fucking skid. Just let you know what a big one.
A big, you cannot put a price on what does it Dana,
Ciara brings to this Boston Bruin defense. All right, a frame bridge.
All right? If you previously listened to this show,
you've heard me talk about frame bridge. Hey, relax. Okay.
Some people fast forward through these things. They may,
they make it super easy and affordable to cut to custom frame your favorite
things. You got a nice Dick Pic. Ah, they got the frame for you.
I'm from art and prints and posters to the photos on your phone.
They're expert team handcrafts each custom frame here are the new US handcrafts
it. I thought they just measured it.
They hand craft this thing and we'll send it to you and in days,
not weeks or months. All right? That's why you're gonna love frame bridge.
That's why sending a custom frame picture with frame pitch is the go to gift
this holiday season. That's a great gift. You don't have any fucking money.
Just frame a cell phone picture, you and the other person.
Just write like friends or smile. Put a little Emoji on it.
This is beautiful.
These guys are going to save you a ton of money in a few minutes.
You can build an order, a
thoughtful personal gift on frame,
bridge dot coms website or straight from your phone.
Their expert team will hand craft a custom frame or just measure it,
picture of frame that fucking fits it right for your picture and we'll drive it
straight to you or someone on your list.
And the best part frame bridge starts at just $39 in shipping is free.
Hey,
in a few minutes you can create a meaningful custom gift for everyone in your
list, a picture of your sibling for you. As you guys got to do for Christmas,
just get a fuck.
Just take a selfie of yourself and then send it to frame bridge and get a
handcrafted photo and just, you know, send it to everybody.
My gift to all of you this holiday season is a picture of me this way,
even though when I'm not there, I can always be there. All right,
pick the perfect
frame@framebridge.com you can preview your item in all their frame styles.
Then upload a picture.
You can even frame an Instagram photo that talent experts at frame bridge will
print and frame your item and ship it straight to you or your loved one.
Your gift arrives in days completely ready to hang and includes a handwritten
gift. Note
that frame bridge help you win the holidays with a thoughtful gift.
That's easy right now you.
All you gotta do is go to frame bridge.com and use the promo code [inaudible].
You'll save 15% off your first order. Now remember,
place your orders by December 18th to ensure delivery by Christmas.
That's Promo Code Bar holiday deadline is December 18th okay,
next up on the docket on it.
Joe Rogan's company on it. Has a new product.
It's called the emulsified MCT oil.
The fuck is that MCT oil is one of the fastest sources of clean fuel for the
body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power up your performance or kickstart a weight
management program. There's a,
there are lots of MCT oil brands out there. I didn't know that,
but there is none like emulsified MCT oil from Onnit available in three
delicious flavors. Coconut, Vanilla and strawberry.
Oh my DNA. Coconut head,
Fenella skin straight emulsified.
MCT oil makes mixes like a cream easily in your more like Gary Sheffield.
You Rub it on your arms there and your morning coffee without the need for a
blender. No mess, no cleanup.
You can even mix it into your favorite foods right now.
If you go to onnit.com/bill you can get on,
it's emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
That's on it. Dotcom.
Did I just girl build to get emulsified slash bill to get emulsified MCT oil for
12% off for any reason. If you don't like it, they'll give you your money back.
No questions asked. They're just mean muggy as you walk out the store,
they're all fucking got those neck muscles. You know,
like they could shrugged his shoulders for days. Why?
Cause it take their emulsified MCT oil. You got nothing to lose.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bill now and get on it.
Okay.
Oh wait. How many? One of these motherfuckers, we've got three more.
Let's get the first three out of the way. What do you say? Tipsy elves.
Everyone is just not a porno by the way.
Tipsy elves.
Have you ever wanted to take advantage of an Elf but it wasn't drunk enough?
Welcome to tipsy elves. Everyone.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater this time of year. Um,
if you want bragging rights for the most talked about sweater,
your Christmas parties. Listen Up.
Talk about your tipsy elves sweater and other products you saw on this website.
Oh God. This is like a fucking hipster website. Um Oh,
that's great. That's so bad. It's good.
A tipsy elves has hundreds of Christmas sweaters designs that are nothing like
you've seen before. They're not for the faint of heart.
Check out the all new 2016 sweaters. You won't find them anywhere else.
Tipsy elves. Sweaters are all about fun,
but are serious on quality and construction.
When you're shopping for your ugly sweater,
check out the other holiday and collegiate attire for yourself or as a gift like
adult onesies. What does that feed pajamas with?
Like a dick hole cutout? Huh? You got like a fucking,
what do they call that when the chicks at the truck stop and it's just the whole
, the guy sticks a glory hole. You've got a glory hole in the front.
You know they made out of wood,
they're wood pajamas and you just stick your Dick through the fucking the
knocked out. Not In the wood. All right. For men, interactive sweaters,
beer pong, corn, cornhole, and Christmas suits.
I didn't want to know what that is for women holiday leggings,
sweater dresses and pajamas.
Right now my listeners get 20% off tipsy elves.com on anything they order on
their site shop now. So you have the best selection to choose from.
And you have the t eh,
you have it in time for your ugly Christmas sweater party.
Go to tipsy elves.com enter my code bar at checkout to get 20% off a sitewide
discounts. That's tipsy elves.com/burr right?
No tipsy elves.com and then my code bar. All right.
Are you kidding me? Oh, I still got three more to go. All right. Fuck this dude.
Fuck this. Okay, let's plow ahead. Where are we? Huh?
32 minutes in. Was there anything else I wanted to fucking talk about?
Uh Oh dude, I started going through my shit cause I'm, I'm,
I'm selling my Prius, right?
So I'm going back and I'm trying to find the title to my car and of course I
can't find this fucking thing. And I find the title to my wife's car,
to my car and my old truck.
And I also found a copy of a title to this 88 Honda accord.
I had like fucking 15 years ago.
Okay.
I had the DX was the LX. You had the LX five speed manual transmission.
What a great fucking car that was. God Damn it. I loved that car. Um,
I found a copy of that, but nothing for the Prius.
And now I gotta go fucking to the DMV and get a copy of it and all that
bullshit. Um, ended up getting rid of that shit.
Move on with my fucking life. I'm
gonna get a fucking God damn conference call coming up here in 10 minutes.
I'll have to finish the rest of the podcast later. I apologize. You know,
that's what it is. Patriots jets. Did you watch that?
How fucking awful that our defense look in the first fucking half. Good Lord.
Um, I mean, I know we're banged up and everything, but uh, I don't know.
Remember that time when we traded Richard Seymour long time ago and every
Patriot fan was like, dude, what the fuck did we do that for?
And then the people who were kind of paying attention, we're like, well look,
there was a deal next year. Who's going to be up for free agency.
He was going to ask for a zillion dollars and we knew we weren't going to give
it to them and then we would have gotten nothing for him.
So we traded them the year before I went on this website and they showed all
that that trickled down from that thing, that trade.
Um, and all the players we got,
how we could be more aggressive because of what we got from Richard Seymour.
I'm hoping the same thing is that happened this year with, uh,
I didn't know if we traded Chen Chandler Jones and we lost them to free agents,
free agency, but a fucking dude that we sent to Cleveland,
which I keep Jamie Collins. Maybe that'll turn into something, but uh,
I don't know. It's unhealthy as we are. I'm not, I'm not, I don't know.
I'm not giving him, I never came up. I'm just saying, you know what the fuck.
It's the Goddamn jets.
They will fucking go and crazy to every fucking play they made.
They were going fucking nuts. You know,
like they just fucking like that was their playoff game,
whichever respected they fucking came to play. But anyways,
so this whole fucking weekend, all I did was watch football and I,
and I was looking for that title and in the process of looking for the title,
I cleaned up a bunch of my shit and I was kinda thinking with the kid coming
along, um, I'm not going to have time to do shit,
but life is going to keep hitting me.
So I want to know where all my insurance forms are.
We're every fucking piece of legal shit that I need. You know what I mean? Like,
do you have your tracking number and all that?
And I'm getting all of that stuff organized and um,
I had all these fucking shit that I held on to for,
I had like fucking my insurance auto insurance contract from like 2007 until
now. And I'm like, it expires 12 months after you get a bill.
You've held onto this shit for nine years longer than you need to.
So I shred it a lot of shit, but a underrated,
just finally going through your office and just organizing everything.
I kind of know where like everything is now. And uh,
I wanna I want to do that kind of for everything that I have.
So when my kid comes here and then takes marker out and draws all over
everything, I'll know where the fucking insurance shit is. Um, all right, let's,
let's read 'em. Let's read some, uh,
some questions here for the week. Stan hope special.
Is it somebody writing in about the great? Doug Stanhope said, Hey,
bill used your promo code to sign up for CSO so I could watch Stan hope's new
special. I've heard nothing but great things. He said, Holy Shit,
you're still my favorite bill. But Stan hope is a genius.
Why do you guys always have to do that?
You still got to take the piss out of me. I know. He's fucking tremendous.
You know, why can't you just say, this guy's a great comedian.
I'll tie it bell I baguette, but this guy, oh yeah.
Everybody in the Internet's got to do that. If you have a good band,
someone's got his, just sit there and be like, dude, I love you guys,
but it's fucking Doug, Stan hope man. These are fucking,
I know he's a genius. You didn't have to take the piss out of me.
A's fucking better than I am fucking cunt. Um,
he said I wish more people knew about him.
I felt the same way about you years ago when you were just a comedy baby.
A tell you people at Netflix to give 'em the Chappelle treatment. Uh,
love you man. Um, yeah, I've heard nothing but great shit about that.
I'm sorry. That's the last to the, the the Ricola
eating on the Mike kind of a fucking amateur. Am I? Um, all right,
well what you're telling me,
every comedian has known about Doug stand help since probably the late nineties.
And um, Doug is, um,
ever watched those cop movies, you know,
and you know that guy you always has to turn in his badge cause he's doing shit
outside the system,
but he's got a good heart and in the end he arrests the bad guy and it's all
good. That's who Stan hope is. Right.
But the entertainment industry hasn't figured that out yet.
But eventually he will be standing on their fucking city hall steps as they give
them the key to the city. That's what I'm hoping. But, um,
my rule with all of these guys is I don't watch this standup special just cause
I can't have an hour and an hour and a half of this shit floating around in my
head cause it'll influence, you know, I'm of to paranoid about that.
But my rule is that with all these guys, Rogan, Stan Hope,
Louie Chappelle,
all of these guys that if they come into a comedy club that I'm at,
and a, they're going to go do a set. I will watch them. That's how I do it.
But I don't watch their specials cause I'm too paranoid about any sort of
overlap or whatever. But, um, having said that,
every time Doug, Stan hope's specials come out, always,
always,
always for like three to six months afterwards comics that just taken me aside.
Go do it. If you seen Stan hope's new fucking special. Um, yeah,
he's fucking incredible. And, um, I don't know.
Well, I dunno why. I Dunno. Why,
what it is about comics like that, that they just a,
I don't know if the industry just won't give the same,
don't you know what it is at the end of the day where if you ever have a
question about an artist you like,
just imagine Doug Stanhope on TV trying to sell your Ritz crackers. Okay.
How long could he talk about those crackers before they would have a major
fucking PR? And I think that's what it comes down to. All right.
There's the people that are truly are the greats and then there's the people
that are really good, but they won't fucking, you know,
they can sell a box of Ritz crackers. That's what it kind of comes down to.
And Doug, Stan hope is one of those fucking guys. What makes them great?
So maybe that's what it is. I like that this guy's like that.
You gotta have the fucking road guys. You know what I mean?
You can't have everybody just fucking hanging out with the, I don't know,
Eddie Showbiz, you know, at a fucking, you know, in an election party.
You know what I mean? And talking about issues. Hi,
I'm fucking Sandy San Sam cakes and I'm here to talk about the fucking, uh,
the slaughter of baby seals and all of that. You know, that main stream,
like I'm step off your private jet,
take the time to give a fuck for 20 minutes before you get back to yelling at
your personal assistant. There's that level of uh,
connecting with people and then there's what Stan hope does,
where he fucking goes, where they're at. That guy is literally played,
I would say, you know,
let's say there's 10,000 comedy clubs in this country.
He's played at least 9,998 of them.
That fucking guy has played as much as I've done a bunch of play.
That guy has been fucking everywhere and that's why,
that's why he's as good as he is, that his work ethic, he's fucking prolific.
He's one of my favorites of all time.
So I wish I knew what the name of the specialist maybe I can like go to look at.
I'll look that up. You know what I gotta to hit pause.
I get this fucking conference call.
I'll be right back and I'll also have the name of the special.
What do you think about that?
And this will be like fucking like an eighth of a second year life.
Just like those fucking millennials. What their virtual reality glasses,
what's said over there and Whoa, it's guy.
I fucking hate that commercial where the kids are sitting there freaking the
fuck out. Like they don't realize that it's not a real world.
And then the greedy corporate cons. Then what do they got to do?
They got to have the old curmudgeon guy like me actually older than me.
And then what are you kids do?
And then he puts it on and then of course he's completely enamored, right?
And now he's going to be into this shit. Get the fuck Outta here.
Fuck those glasses. I swear to God man,
like the amount of people that are going to get mugged while they have those
fucking things on in public. Cause I'll tell her right now,
these fucking kids are so goddamn stupid.
They're wearing one of those in like on a city bus and just fucking have it on
there. You know what I mean?
That's like walking into white Cornell's little fucking baskets
with what?
Cobra in there and you stick your head in with your virtual reality glass
glasses and you can't see the snake anymore cause you're in fucking a middle
earth. Ah, the old man's coming out of me this week. All right.
Hang on a second.
Okay.
All right. Now back, just like dad, an hour of fucking conference calling. Huh?
Don't you wish you were me? Is there anything better than a conference call?
Hey, let's get on and make a call and have a conference.
Okay,
everybody can talk and share ideas.
Have another hour of your life go by that you're never gonna get back.
All right? You know, this is how old I am.
You know what's on my Christmas list this year? You know,
this pajamas I've had the same pair of fucking pajamas for like I don't,
I don't even know how long. Like, I don't know, maybe, uh,
early two thousands, you know,
I'm trying to think all this shit that I've watched on TV and these jam jams and
they've just had it, it's fucking over and I've actually dropped.
Not even the hint, I just demanded. And you get to when you get to be my age,
cause no one gives a shit about you anymore.
You can't ask for something for Christmas. You gotta start,
you gotta make demands with like a touch of a threat, Kate, I'm just saying,
okay, just throw, put this out there,
but we be in everybody's best interest.
If I've got some new pajamas this Christmas, that's all I'm saying. Okay. Huh?
You like where you live in? You like this phone.
Okay.
There better be some jam jams under the fucking tree. Um,
anyways, and then no matter what, then he ended up being wrong.
Like I had a fucking argument with my wife this week about the way she fucking,
you know, stacks up the dishes in the sink. You know what I mean?
I Dunno if your wife does this shit,
but there'll be like a pot sitting in the fucking sink and then they have a
plate, right? What do they do?
They stick the plate on top of the thing and then they take another bowl and
they stick it on top of the plate and then you just got this leaning Tower of
Horse Shit and you fucking sink. It's like,
why don't you put the plate underneath the pot and then just see if the pot can
fit in the bowl.
The ball could fit in the fucking pot and then it takes like a third of this
space. Yeah, no,
you have to take a door to that fucking gay gay, you know,
make rather rather than make,
it looks like this 10 weeks of fucking dishes here. This is like two meals,
you know, one of those fucking,
one of those fucking dumb arguments where you end up getting in your car and
driving away. And then afterwards you just sitting there going, what the fuck?
I'm literally driving down the street right now,
contemplating giving this woman everything that I own and moving into a one
bedroom apartment over the way. She stacks dishes in the sink.
But I'll tell you when you live with somebody, it seems so fucking important.
All right, time off. Dear Billy body. [inaudible] I think you're awesome.
Thank you. And I have a crush on you and I'm,
hey,
there you go. I thought the left term was going to be, and I'm a dude. Um,
I love the, you take care of yourself and are always striving to be better.
This is great. I've, you know what,
if I were you guys listening to this right now,
I would be highly suspect of whether or not I actually wrote this in. Um,
my husband and I haven't seen you live yet and we want,
we want to this year, if you happen to be coming back to Wisconsin, well,
where the hell were you a few months ago? You know,
when did you develop this crush in October? I was there in September. Uh,
do you think you'll be touring as much or will you be taking the year off to
spend time with your newborn? Love you and I love Nia. Um,
oh, I'm totally going to be the absentee father. I already have that worked out,
you know, going to be doing like 56
weeks on the road. Now obviously my schedule will be a little bit different. Um,
be honest with you. I'd, I don't know. Um, I do know, however, that,
um, you know,
when I was getting ready to do my special rather than doing one night in every
city, you know, when I did that little,
I played a smaller theater and I spent a week in Durham,
like just Thursday, Friday, Saturday, and I,
it's so much more enjoyable way of doing the road rather than doing one night in
Durham one night and fucking Poughkeepsie one night here.
It just becomes a fucking thrash. And when you're an older fellow like myself,
you know, I like going to a place, hanging out with the people,
seeing where they eat, go into a game. That's how I always fucking did it.
So I'm gonna try to do more of that.
And I was just in Madison and funny you should bring up going back to Milwaukee.
Uh, uh, Wisconsin was, I haven't been to Milwaukee and um,
well I guess it was October of, it's amazing. I can always remember this.
It was like October of 2015 so it's been, uh,
we'll call it December at this point. So it's been 14 months. So,
um,
definitely in 2017 not only will I be coming back to Milwaukee,
uh, I plan on spending like, uh,
three or four days there because that Milwaukee had not only a great cigar bar,
it had the best fucking steam of any place I've ever been to.
And it was at a hotel called the Pfister,
I swear to God at the hotel is called the Pfister. It's P, f.
I. S. T. E. R. If you add Milwaukee, dude, I'm telling you man, Milwaukee,
don't sleep on Milwaukee. Great people, great food,
great fucking Lakefront property for a song. Right?
And the sickest fucking steam room you're ever going to go into.
You get your own private like lifestyles of the rich and famous fucking, it's,
it's unbelievable. So, um,
no, when you get to be my fucking age,
that's the type of shit that's appealing to you on the road.
You know what I mean? It's not like God, dude, you gotta go to Miami,
they got all these hot chicks down there. I'm a fucking creepy old married guy.
Where is there a steam room?
Listen to me. I got to Berkeley locis
I ain't got time for the WHO was, um, anyways, uh,
so yeah,
tonight I'm actually doing the Steve Allen Theater and whatever the fuck they're
calling it now, and I'm just basically running my whole new hour.
I'm so fucking excited.
I've gotten past the whole morning period of missing my old jokes.
I'm past the whole now. Not as funny as I was on stage and you know,
I took all the bullets out of the gun. I'm shooting fucking plagues up here. Um,
this is my favorite fucking thing in the world.
I'm so excited tonight about the show. Um,
and just seeing where it goes.
And I got a couple of buddies of mine coming down who were musicians,
so they're going to get to see that whole fuck cause I already told him,
I was like, all right, you guys want to come down. This is gonna,
this is gonna be the real deal. This is not the a old tried and true there.
All right. Coping with being single. Oh.
Oh I already like this right here. Hey Billy, master of fuck. It's um,
I've been single my entire life.
I'm into my later twenties and still haven't found any lady that I really hit it
off with. I've struggled with being single for a long time,
but I've been working through it. I'm okay with it,
but I still have my dark moments. My question to you is,
when you were single for all those years, did you ever get lonely or feel alone?
Uh, did you ever think you'd be single forever?
What helped you to endure through those times and how did you cope with it?
Yes to all of that. Yup. As I figured some things out.
I've been doing bucket list types of stuff that helps me get through it. Yeah,
I do. That's a great thing to do when you're single.
Go do all that shit you want to do cause a, you know, you meet somebody else.
Yeah. You know, you might not have the time.
This person says, I've gone to see some of my favorite bands play live.
I've traveled a little and I've been working towards finding a career path that
I really enjoy. So I believe I'm doing some good things,
but I still have my days when I suffer through it. A little a,
but I've learned to sit in that pain for a bit and find good things.
Uh, saying something dumb at work. Oh that's the next one.
I thought that was the guy signing off or the woman,
whoever the fuck does says I'm all right. My question to you is,
you've been single all those years. Did you ever get lonely or feel alone?
Here's the thing, I was never lonely for the first,
I don't know how many years of my life until I had a girlfriend.
And then lost my girlfriend. And then after that,
that's the first time I felt like, oh, I don't have a chick. It's weird.
I didn't have my first serious girlfriend till I was like 23,
something like that, 22, 23 years old. So I was fine
with being single. And that thing lasted like, I dunno, like eight, nine months.
And uh,
I ended up breaking up with her and that was right before I started doing stand
up. And, um,
I remember the first six weeks of being like, fuck,
how long is it going to take for me to get over this person? And, um,
it's weird, man, like getting over a person, it's like,
it's like quitting the booze. It's a habit. They're a habit,
you know what I mean? I always call him at this time,
then he got to fill up those fucking times, but you just can't fill them up.
You kinda gotta go through the morning of them not being there anymore and then
you start filling them up with other stuff. But like, dude, I think travel,
seeing bands and everything. The great thing is too,
the fact that you're our lady,
the fact that you're single and you feel alone is a very healthy thing.
You know what I mean? Now,
if you are totally fucking single and you didn't feel lonely at all,
I guess maybe you know,
maybe you're just a fucking someone who doesn't want to be with anybody.
That could also be cause as long as you're not out killing people,
you know what I mean? As long as you don't feel the need to hunt,
as long as you're not feeling that,
and as long as you are right with whatever it is you're doing,
then you should be fine too. During your fucking late twenties through,
trust me, someday you're going to be married,
you're going to have a fucking kid coming like I got right now,
and you're all of a sudden, all your drum videos you're thinking,
I'm going to get, I gotta get rid of those. I got to get rid of all this shit.
I got to get rid of all of this stuff.
And there's this feeling that I'm having right now.
Will I ever play drums again?
But fortunately I married the coolest woman ever so I just was able to sit down
with her. This,
this might help you if you're afraid to get in a relationship because you feel
like you're going to lose all of this stuff.
You just let the person you're with know what's important.
And I already said that. My wife, I said, listen,
here's the deal like once a week, okay, you pick a day,
once a week when this kid is not sleeping through the night and you can just go
somewhere,
get a massage or just go someplace and fucking sleep or I'll take the kid and go
drive around. I'll let you sleep for fucking hours and hours,
whatever the hell it is. Okay. All you gotta do is let me keep playing drums,
taking drum lessons and that shit.
That'll be my spot thing cause I don't really need to sleep cause I'm a fucking
lunatic.
And also I'll still get to do the road twice a month and you know,
I'll use that time to sleep.
I'll do my shows at night and then I'll go right to the hotel and I will sleep
till the fucking cats come home. The cows come, whatever the fucking animal is,
and then I'll come back recharged. You know what I mean? But we,
we make sure that we kind of worked that stuff out with each other. So, um,
if you're afraid to get in a relationship,
just know that there's a cool people out there as long as you, uh,
I don't know. Yeah. You never heard me say this,
but women in general pretty cool if you just tell them what the fucking deal is.
Um, but I have issues with women. So even as I said that,
just picturing how many women just
went like, oh my God, yes. That like,
that annoyed me even though they were agreeing with me. It's weird.
I got a lot of fucking issues. So, um, yeah, I definitely felt,
I felt like I was never going to meet the one.
I felt like there was something wrong with me and all of this type of shit.
Just know this.
Every one of your friends that's in a relationship is secretly envious of you,
even if they're with the right person. That's how much fucking work it is,
you know, every once in a while, you know, I look at fucking, um, you know,
I'll look at up, I'll look at a playboy like Joe de Rosa and I'll be like,
God damn it man. What the fuck did he's got? He's, you know,
he's key skis living the life, you know, but then, you know,
you come home and your wife make some fucking cookies. You like,
this is pretty cool too. Alright. Saying something dumb at work.
So I'll say to this person, you, you, you find, dude,
you're in your late twenties. Um,
the same way that you have goals with, um,
your career in bucket list stuff should have,
she should have some goals about the kind of person that you want to be with
like a women after I actually do shit like that.
Women actually sit down and think about the kind of, guys don't do that.
We just sort of ping pong the wrong. I'll stick my fucking tick in that.
You know, we idiots. Um, but if you actually, you know,
get a little bill Belichick, you know, see what's missing, you know,
from your half, see what you're looking for. What do you want,
you know, do you want a woman that wants kids?
Do you want a woman that can cook and your traditional,
do you want a career woman? Like what do you want? You know,
I can tell you right now, if you want a woman that can cook,
we'll actually sit down and cook.
I'll tell you right now that's like a, I dunno,
you know, like every, once every, I don't know how many years they have,
they have that and that 1983 draft,
like women do not foe women's do not be cooking anymore.
All this feminism shit, it's really a sad thing. But men of, you know,
it's our fault because we didn't put a value on it. Great.
I'm out there busting my ass. You Ain't here pickling cucumbers, right?
I just gave him shit. Making a meal for somebody.
One of the nicest things you could ever do. You know? But what happened?
How we talk. Shit we gave, we didn't give him a fucking respect him now looking,
they don't want to cook up.
The mothers are out there running around Willy Nilly wearing pantsuits running
and running for president of the United States. I mean, that's a mad job.
No kidding.
You're the funniest fucking thing ever is how sick you have to be to want to be
president. The fact that Hillary Clinton is depressed right now,
that she didn't get a job. Well,
she was going to have to put her head on the pillow every night knowing she just
made a decision that bombs were just dropped and possibly landed on somebody's
baby and she, she's,
she's depressed that she didn't get that fucking job. It's unbelievable.
What do you think her pajamas look like?
She definitely has the fucking guy once, right? Like the flannel
wearing the pants. Um, I liked the pantsuits.
I don't know why everybody gave a shit about it. I always like Rhoda, you know,
Rhoda, Mary Tyler Moore, they fucking filled those things out. You know,
walking around with your little bungees up against that Rey on. All right.
Say something dumb at work saying something dumb at work. Okay.
What do we got here? Um, yeah. Fuck you guys. Mind if I just do the last bit of,
you know what? That's a country move.
I'll read this and then I'll do the advertising. Hey Bill. Longtime Fan.
Probably listened to you too much. T once again, you start with the compliment,
then you give me the old fucking Shank to the kidney. Longtime Fan.
Probably listened to you too much. All right. Too. Too much. When it's too much.
That's, that's two o's. All right. All right. Here's my problem.
I was at, I was at Work Party, I think you mean at a work party?
Talking to my colleagues. I work as an RN in an ICU.
Okay. That's a registered nurse in an intensive care unit. Huh?
I have some nurses in my family. Uh, we have a new
to our unit hired joining us,
but she's worked as a nurse for 25 years already.
My friends said she's joining my rotation.
I say out loud in my typical bill,
blurt burn a inflection Ogh is now how cheese.
Another old broadened our line there.
Several colleagues heard this and now every day is some new twist on my comment.
Some chirping is fine, but half the unit is over 50.
I want some joke comment.
I don't want some joke comment to help me haunt me for years. Bill,
how do I get this to go away? Thanks. Um,
okay.
I, I would just say with them, I, I just, I wouldn't back off.
I would just keep doing the Archie bunker and she's another role.
Broaden a line there and then when they, they, yeah, this lady to world,
you know, good. All of you with your menopause,
but you can't do that at work now.
You can't do that work now because you're not making it a safe place.
This is a safe space.
Ugh.
Oh my God. That alone, that alone gave Trump about 200,000 votes.
Fucking adults saying, you're not making this a safe space.
It just fucking did.
They all have a meeting and they came up with that fucking horrific. That what,
what was the second choice? I just don't understand that.
I, I, you know something, I have to be honest with you.
I don't know how you get out of that and right there,
that's why I do what I do for a fucking living because there's no way I could be
in that level of a childish fucking environment that people,
what did you mean about that? What do, what am I,
how many fucking thoughts have you had in your head today? Your old fucking bag.
That if they were publicized that you'd even still have a job as a nurse.
Get the fuck Outta here. Yeah. You don't, you know what? Just just, you know,
women like suites just come and just bake a fucking pie or some shit.
Okay.
Ugh. Anyways, I'm sorry. Going through that. I'm sorry you were quoting me,
but you know what? You also kind of blamed me a little bit there. We say,
listen to me too much. You were thrown a little bit of blame.
You went a little Peyton manning there.
We had protection issues as what you just did to me there. Um,
okay.
I don't know how much is, but you're still bringing that, yeah.
You still bring that up?
You should've heard what I said this morning or something like that.
I would just do that. Um, that is kind of funny.
Who gives a shit? Do you like the job?
That all depends on how much you like the job because or watch he's old.
You're all old. I wouldn't fuck any of you, you know, I dunno. I Dunno.
I don't know how to get out of that. Um,
anybody has any suggestions tweeted at me and I'll fucking retweet it.
Maybe this person follows me on Twitter and can help them out. Uh,
would it help if I know if you are a man or a woman? I have no idea. All right.
Dollar Shave Club. I'm guessing a man. If you're a woman,
you're the coolest woman ever that you said that. No. The all broad here.
All right. Dollar Shave Club. Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing,
affordable raises right to your door every month. So you can get a great shape.
But razors aren't the only thing you need in the bathroom.
What about some shower stuff? Huh?
What about when you wash it off the old tape?
It turns out dollar Shave Club thought of that too.
They just came out with a new line of shower products,
shampoo and body wash called the wanderer. Well,
I'm the type of guy likes the washes nuts.
The fragrances are unlike anything on the market.
There's subtle and actually smelled like real natural ingredients.
There are a lot of body washes out there that make you smell like a teenager.
This mint and Cedar Wood bodywash is amazing. It makes you smell incredible.
It's like you're eating ice cream next to the fireplace. Um,
you've got to give it a try.
What the fuck is so great about mint and Cedar Wood Body?
Are those two different ones? I hope.
Um,
like you're fucking eaten ice cream over Ron Burgundy's house rich mahogany. Uh,
you got to give it a try. Once you're in the club,
you'll see the products are amazing. The service is world class.
There's no longterm commitments, no hidden fees,
and you can cancel whenever you want.
And Best of all that given away a one month trial of any one of their fucking
races for a dollar with free shipping. And after that,
it's just a few bucks a month.
Get your online dollar trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar that's dollar shave
club.com/burr oh who's next? Two more to go.
O M v m t movement watches pronounced movement was founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality quality minimalist products at revolutionary prices.
With over 500,000 watches sold to customers and 160 plus countries around the
fucking world movement watches has solidified itself as the world's fastest
growing watch company. All right,
a holiday thoughts status, please be conversational.
Choose one and make this your own. All right, I'm going to choose this one.
We get it.
Fuckos holiday shop and can be fucking had.
This is me making my own. I just say fucking Boston accent,
but thanks to movement watches all that gift giving horse shit.
Anxiety can disappear with the press of the button.
These watches make the perfect purchase for just about any person in your life.
Guy Or girl. Remember, they just start at 95 bucks. You know what?
Even if you don't like somebody spending 95 bucks is too much money.
Only get this for people that you care about. You know what I mean?
Get everybody else. You can get a fucking bumper sticker. All right?
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to move and
watches.com/burr this watch has a really clean design. All right? Seriously.
Evidently,
I've been getting compliments on the one that I don't wear ever since I put it
on. Now is the time to step up your watch game. Go to movement,
watches.com/burr join the movement. Get a $95 watch for 500 bucks now,
$500 watch for 95 bucks today. Lastly, but not leastly,
stamps.com everybody, oh Jesus,
Saint Nick is coming here for all the good Christians out there. He's a saint,
but he doesn't care about Muslims.
Jews are fucking a Buddhist people, right?
What about all those a aboriginals? Whatever the fuck they worship, Huh?
How come Santa Claus doesn't go to them? You know why? Cause they'd be like,
oh my God, it's another white man.
And they fucking put a poison dart enough and it served them right. You know,
it served them right. Even though he didn't do anything. He'd be a martyr,
you know, big stupid red suit laying face down in it, right?
stamps.com with the holidays almost.
I'm surprised that government has never tried to set up Santa Claus by sending
them into some area where there's indigenous people.
Just set them up for a fight the way we did when we took over this fucking
country. You know,
so we could justify the genocide of those wonderful people that when they killed
a squirrel, they used all of it unlike us. What do we do? Huh?
Through the inside of the fucking womp rat.
And then use the rest of the hat for what is a goof?
stamps.com everybody white people to Frat boys of people. I'm sorry.
stamps.com. Um, what? The holiday's almost here.
You don't have time to go to the post office. Well you do,
but who the fuck wants to go?
It'll be packed with everyone mailing holiday gifts and packages,
so so do what I do. Do what I do.
You stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can void all the hassle man,
or going to the post office during the busy holiday season,
buying print official us postage, using your own computer or printer,
print the postage for any letter or package the instance you needed.
Then the mailman picks it up. You never have to go to the post office again.
It's a fucking dream.
I use stamps.com whenever I'm sending out any of my posters.
Anytime I'm selling some shit at the end of a fucking show.
Anytime I think to myself, you know what? I haven't,
I haven't Shaked enough sweaty fucking palms of complete strangers.
You know what I mean?
I want to feel that warm arm pit of a taller person as they put their arm around
me sitting right on my shoulder, seeping into my fucking button-down. Yeah.
That's when I send out all my posters. Everybody,
you can print the postage and all that shit. Then the mailman picks it up.
All right. Right now a I can do. You're better.
I can get you an even better offer than what's on the homepage.
Sign up for stamps.com right now and use my last name bird to get a four week
trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes postage in the digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone.
Stop the homepage and type in burger that stamps.com enter [inaudible]. Okay,
it's over. All right, well let's, let's finish off the rest of these here.
Oh, key dokey. Fun Times in Syria.
Billie the cunt. It's Martin from Sweden. Thank you for this podcast.
No worries. It's been more than 10 years since I was almost raped in Syria.
What the fuck? Although time passes,
the story seems to never get old.
All right.
You know, I, I,
you really just going to fuck with me on this God damn level here.
Am I supposed to believe this is true? How time flies? It's like you're,
you're looking back fondly on this. This is weird.
I was 17 when me and my class went on a school trip to Syria,
puts in parentheses, Middle East. Go Fuck yourself, Jason.
I know I'm American. I know we're serious. All right.
One day all of my classmates were out snorkeling.
I stayed in the hostel bed because I had a fever.
Two aspirins later I found myself out looking for my class in sauna,
like temperatures with a foolish mindset. My blonde,
blue eyed nature fit, figured the aspirin had cured my fever,
so I was in quite good spirits for about seven miles of searching for the other
Swedes. This is creeping me out.
Now the fever was kicking back and in at this point,
uh,
and I'd given up my endeavors of snorkeling.
I didn't know where I was or how to get back to my hostel. At that moment,
a taxi pulled over. The driver asked if I wanted to get a Lyft.
I said I didn't have any money to offer,
but he insisted that no money was needed for the ride. Oh, Jesus is right. Yes.
High fever and good amounts of gullibility led me to step into the cab and off
we went, hi, welcome to Syria. The taxi guy said, you are very beautiful.
I didn't want to be rude. So I said, thanks back at him.
Then he asked me if I liked women. Sure. I replied.
Then he asked if I liked big women share. I said, and he said, ah,
you like big because same with your Dick.
He said,
what? At this point I regretted getting to the what the fuck? Ah,
you like big because same with your Dick. He said, okay.
I thought this was a woman. So it's a guy and now there's dude. Oh Jesus.
Here we go. At this point,
I regret getting to the taxi very much in the moment after he was reaching for
my package while he was driving.
Oh two that's it. Oh, you in the front seat.
That's when you got to do,
what was that fucking Schwartzenegger movie where he gets on the plane with that
guy and he pretends to tie your shoe and he comes up with the elbow death and
drives this spine of his nose into his brain and then puts his little fucking a
Tommy Bahama ad over his face and he goes, don't disturb him. He's dead tired.
That's what you needed to do was that rod deal.
I think he needed to go rod deal there anyways.
I say no stop. I said, but the tracks, he driver was very persistent.
He wondered why he couldn't touch my penis. Like I owed him the right to do.
So I was feeling extremely vulnerable,
being a teenager foreigner and having a high fever at all.
I shouted at him to stop the car, but he kept on going, dude,
you've got to start going Dave. The Hammer Schultz here. Right?
You gotta fucking, he gotta start swinging, man. Uh, but he kept on going.
I thought about jumping out of the car, but I was, it was going way too fast.
I also didn't want to start a fight and risk crashing the car. Ah,
Jesus. At some point, dude, you've got to pick your poison. Did it have airbags?
Picture pictures of Taliban rape cades with pulp fiction.
Kim's suits and gag balls was entering my mind as the taxi car continued to
drive on without any intent to pull over. This is really happening.
Oh my Lord. I thought to myself,
luckily we came to a traffic light and I managed to get out of the car and on
the pavement I started running when I heard him screaming at me.
One Syrian pound, Mr Oh God,
now you're going to get paid for getting,
you got to pay him for moving less than you.
I got over the experience pretty soon and it would have not affected my life to
any extent. No fucking way.
People sometimes want me to tell the almost raped story and given pressures of
the taxi driver.
I can't help to think how unfunny it would be if I were a girl almost getting
raped in Syria. Yeah, but you're a guy, so it's fucking hell.
Everything that happens to a guy's hilarious. Nobody gives a shit.
My question to you is, why is this kind of a f,
why is this story kind of funny if it happened to men but awful in every way if
it happened to a woman. Your thoughts on that after you go fuck yourself.
PSA Hi to lovely Nia. Um,
this is why it's funny because you're able to fight him off.
It's a guy with an accent grabbing your Dick when you tell this story. I,
my friend, my friend, just like your dead baby, right? It's just hilarious.
I remember one night we were down at the comedy cellar.
We were all telling the stories about getting molested as kids and it was one of
the funniest nights I've ever had.
It was so fucking Cathartic and we would just cry and laughing.
And I remember all the comics where, you know, I dunno,
had a different upbringing. We're looking at it like it was fucked up,
but it was fucking hilarious to me. Um, and if you told me this story,
I would be laughing my ass off still knowing that you,
you probably have some sort of fucking issue and all the pens and all the pens,
you know, if that was the first person that ever touched you, you know,
if no girl ever gave you a hand job,
the fact it was the first guy that ever did it, you know,
is Harry fucking hand coming over. You know, they could possibly fuck you up,
but you know, okay, you had a little bit of sexual activity. Maybe it doesn't,
you know, it's Kinda like, you know, if you're a relief pitcher and you,
you gotta, you got some saves under your belt, you let up a home run. Yeah,
give me another fucking ball. But if that's your first fucking pitching me,
that can fuck with you. Um,
why is it not funny? Uh,
when it happens to a woman's the same reason why it's like watching a guy get
punched in the head is fucking funny. You know, if he was like talking shit,
it's fucking funny. You know what I mean? But like, you know, kids, women,
animals like this, just never anything funny about watching them get abused.
But this just something hilarious about guys.
I would say the reason why you get having your Dick grabbed and get molested is
funny. His big, the same reason why the three stooges is funny. You know?
Imagine the three stooges. If it was women, you know,
grabbing each other by the hair and slapping each other in the face,
maybe that'd be a little funny. I Dunno. It's just like a guy thing.
We like slapstick and there's just something funny about him grabbing you.
Fuck stick in some car and then he charged you one Syrian pound.
You know what it really comes down to is I imagined being gay is not accepted
even remotely and serious. So this guy thought like, all right,
even if this doesn't go down or if it does go down,
this story leaves this country and goes back to Sweden. Um,
so in the way I'm going to say the cab driver was the victim and not you.
And stop being so selfish. Now I'm fucking with you. Uh,
I'm sorry that happened to you. Um, well you do, I mean,
I mean you were kind of asking for it cause you were on cold medication.
You know, I'm going to blame the victim here. Well, I mean,
what were you wearing? Um, I dunno dude. That's one of the more a,
I'd want to say. That's one of the more fucked up stories I've ever heard,
but a yeah, that, that just goes into that file.
I've heard enough of those ones. Um, yeah, that's why it's not funny. Um,
so I would actually say that you are fucked up.
There's no way you're not fucked up cause that happened to you. And there's, um,
is that feeling where it's just like,
why is that funny when that happens to a guy and then you feel like you can't
fucking, uh, that you should just, yeah. You know, I'm over it.
Like why would you, that's a horrific fucking thing that happened to you.
And I'm even like over the whole
thing, cause it's a guy like a, you know, fucking shake it off, shake it off,
and it's part of growing up. There's always gonna be,
you have a paper route or something like that.
There'll be some Weirdo come at your junk at some point.
But that's just how it is. I remember when that fucking, um,
okay,
that lady cut the dude's Dick off and put it in the garbage disposal.
One of those shows. It's not the view. I think it's the talk the Asian Lady,
she was reading it and as she was reading the details, they were all snickering,
laughing. And I remember that bit I was doing,
what if some guy cut a woman's titty off and threw it in the garbage disposal?
I mean,
they would have done a week long special on that and they would have tried to
help the lady out raise some money to get her a prosthetic.
You know what I mean? So a bra wouldn't be all lopsided.
That's what the fuck they do. But Abbott's to a guide, just fucking hilarious.
And I also think that that's why guys is so fucking funny, you know,
cause uh, you know, if a woman gets molested, it's a tragedy.
If it happens to a guy, it's a sketch. We really don't have any options.
You just gotta shake it off man.
Yeah.
You know, having said all that, dude, I'm sorry that happened to you.
I'm sure you're emotionally fucked up about it,
but I would love to hear that story one time cause I want to hear you imitating
the guy,
you know, and then listen to everybody interrupted
the, so wait, how fast were you go and dude, you couldn't jump on in the car.
He's grabbing your deck and then everybody be laughing going, yeah,
but get jumped out. Then he'd be like holding onto your Dick.
Like Steve has happened. The car half part of the car, right.
Stretching out your Dick. You know,
and then you have one of those needle dicks cause it's not going to give you any
more girth. He's just going to, that's what the whole fucking thing would be.
And then all your friends would laugh and say that you wanted it.
You know what I mean? Why didn't you sit in the back like a normal person?
Why did you sit up front? You know, that's what guys would do.
And they would laugh. You know, you'd just laugh your way through it.
So anyways, I guess I'm going to stop there on the, uh,
I can't, let's stop on something positive. Once again,
I have two benefits that are coming up to two friends of mine that are no longer
here. Um, peak coming. Um,
memorial is going to be December 6th at the laugh factory.
I will tweet that link and the Patrice O'Neal,
the five year anniversary of his passing is today. And um,
the one truly positive thing that came out of that is we get to remember him and
we get to see our friends and we get to raise some money for his loved ones
every year.
And it's going to be February 21st to Tuesday 2017 at the New York City Center.
Um, thank you to all who, uh,
take the time to check it out and buy some tickets, uh, means the world to me.
That's it. Go fuck yourselves. Oh, by the way,
if you want to donate to this podcast, uh, and not have to give any money,
if you're doing some Christmas shopping on Amazon,
go to bill bird.com first click on the podcast page.
You Click on the Amazon link doesn't cost you any, any extra money.
I just get credit for driving traffic there. If you want to do it, I get it.
If you don't, I understand that said,
go fuck yourselves and I'll check it on you on Thursday.